We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. uh, there is a caller who calls infrequently
his name.
His real name as far as I know is Troy York,
but he calls in with all sorts of different
characters.
He has one called the Jamal Jenkins, who is
a black college student.
He has one called Ramon Ramos, who's like
a Hispanic guy.
He has a, uh, all these different characters
here.
He is just as Troy York attacking me for even
thinking about interviewing janky Ugur and
of course attacking janky Ugur physical appearance,
which is the height of debate, right?
When you, when you can't win on substance,
just attack the way somebody looks.
Yeah.
Why did you have that big fat idiot scene
ogre on your show?
The man is an idiot.
He's a stupid, he makes the Les look so stupid
and you don't even realize it.
What's going to be next?
You're going to have Michael Moore, uh, on
your show with, with talking with the Detroit
tigers hand and you'll be, you'll be interviewing
him.
And what, why do you always have dr John garden?
Ron, uh, Oh, he's talking about Trump's psychological
problems when in fact it is the far left and
crazy academia.
Yeah.
Outlet media like yourself who really had
the psychological problems concerning, uh,
president Trump.
Yeah.
Wow.
Absolutely devastating.
And of course you will notice that no substantive
arguments made there by Troy York about Genki
huger merely saying that jank Ugur is weight
is something that he finds relevant.
Um, and basically leaving it there.
These are the types of folks we're fighting.
Okay?
So, and I, I say that not so that you figure
out how to go and argue with them.
I say that so that you don't waste your breath.
Let's focus on, get out the vote.
Why would we debate with that person and say,
Hey, you should really change your vote.
They're, they're gone.
They're gone.
Let's find people that already agree with
us and get them to go out and vote.
We have a great bonus show today.
We are going to talk about the, the boy Scouts
are really struggling and Mormons who typically
love the boy Scouts.
Mormons are pulling 400,000 kids out of the
boy Scouts and this is going to be even worse
for the boy Scouts.
We will also talk about the, I'm a very rich
pharmaceutical family.
The Sackler is they are withdrawing nearly
$11 billion from Purdue pharmaceuticals.
Uh, they, they withdrew nearly $11 billion
from Purdue as the opioid crisis mounted.
We will also talk about the latest on impeachment,
some of the sidebar stories and procedural
kind of funny things that have been going
on, all of that and so much more.
On today's bonus show, how do you access the
bonus show?
It's very easy.
You become a member@joinpacmandotcomoryoubecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show both take under a
minute and get you instant access to the bonus
show.
If you want to be a member, but you're waiting
for the perfect time.
Let me suggest that January 1st is the perfect
time.
On January 1st we will be sending out an email
to everybody on our newsletter with a disgusting,
I mean, it's just a sickening, obscene membership
special where you will be able to lock in
a membership for all of 2020, uh, at a hugely
discounted rate.
If that sounds interesting, sign up for our
newsletter@davidpakman.com upper right at
the top of the right hand column.
Type in your email address, January one, you
will get a very [inaudible]
special email from me with a onetime use code.
Otherwise, I would rather talk to you on the
bonus show today because it is going to be
such a good one.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].